breaking news!
the EU has lowered the allowed
limits on chemical sunscreens
that means the sunscreen you've
been using is killing you
your family
your unborn grandkids
the creepy little worms on your
unborn grandkids' eyelashes
throw out your toxic chemical
sludge burn them in the fire
and buy some 100% safe and natural
sunscreen from my online store
or don't and watch this video first
hi I'm Michelle chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and massive sunscreen nerd
there's been a lot of fear-mongering
about chemical sunscreens
there were scary sounding new stories
sunscreens absorbing into blood killing
coral reefs zinc oxide being
toxic benzene and sunscreens
I've covered most of these before and
they're largely just the media taking
things out of context and sensationalizing them
this is partly for views
because a lot of the media
do survive off ad revenue and affiliate income now
today's topic the EU has been reviewing the safety
of sunscreens and they've lowered some of
the allowed limits of specific ingredients
for example oxybenzone was allowed in sunscreen
at a maximum of six percent but they've now said
"the use of benzophenone-3 oxybenzone
at six percent in body products is not
safe for the consumer" they now recommend
a maximum of 2.2 percent in body products
so some people including scientists from
other fields saw this and started making
really bold statements about how
US sunscreens with six percent are
unsafe and telling people who are
a bit more familiar with this area
to log off because they've taken
this one sentence very literally
to be fair if you did only read this sentence
it does sound a bit scary so let's dive into
why you probably don't need to freak out and
what you might want to do based on this info
a disclaimer this is all going
to be very simplified I am not a
toxicologist but some toxicologists
did help me out with this script
in most of the world sunscreens are cosmetics
and not drugs and this is the case in the EU
there are less strict rules about cosmetics
than drugs but the UV filtering ingredients
that help sunscreens screen out the
sun are still in a special category
their safety gets checked a lot
more than other ingredients and
you can't use them in sunscreens until
they've been added to this special list
this also tells you the rules for using
them including the maximum percentages
when it comes to sunscreens and beauty
products in general people are always
comparing the EU and the US and one of the
biggest differences is the sunscreen ingredients
but the situation is actually kind of the opposite
of what you tend to hear the EU allows a whole
bunch more sunscreen ingredients than the US
the US list hasn't changed since 1999 when
avobenzone was added they only have about seven
commonly used chemical sunscreen ingredients
the EU had about 20 common ones including all
seven from the US for these the two regions had
similar maximum percentages until 2021
when the EU started shaking things up
one thing I love about the EU is that they show
their working and it's relatively easy
to follow it's in these SCCS opinions
these opinions sound a bit more
hand wavy than they actually are
they are scientific opinions
based on interpreting evidence
according to almost 200 pages of guidelines
but that word opinion is important
we'll come back to that later
they're written by the scientific
committee on consumer safety or
the sccs they focus on checking
the safety of consumer products
these self-explanatory names
are putting me out of a job
they look at sunscreen and other personal
care products but also household products
like detergents toys and clothes and
services like tanning and tattooing
their members are mostly toxicologists who
specialize in risk assessment there's also
chemists pharmacists and dermatologists
their very impressive CVs and conflicts
of interest are all publicly available
if you want to do a bit of stalking
every once in a while if there's important
new data or someone's invented a new sunscreen
ingredient the European Commission gets the SCCS
to look at potential risks and write an opinion
these opinions include recommendations for using
the ingredients so below us that percentage or
only in certain products they might even
recommend banning an ingredient altogether
lawmakers will look at these recommendations and
most of the time put them in the cosmetics
regulation that EU products have to follow
in late 2018 the European commission decided
to take a closer look at potential endocrine
disruptors this included some sunscreen
ingredients which is how this opinion came
about "the use of BP3 up to six percent is not
safe for the consumer" but 2.2 percent is safe
let's take a closer look at the word safe first
off the phrase "not safe" as used by toxicologists
in a safety assessment doesn't mean the same as
what we would consider "not safe" in everyday life
scientists use words in weird ways
it's just part of who we are I'm sorry
and this can lead to a lot of confusion
one example is the word significant in science
it's to do with how convincing the data is so if
I'm significantly late in a scientific study
I might be very consistently 10 seconds late
but in everyday life significant is about
how important something is so if my friend
says I'm significantly late I'm probably half
an hour late and they're really pissed at me
with the idea of safe in everyday
life we usually think of things as
either safe or harmful if something
is safe it's not going to hurt you
if something is not safe then there's
a good chance that it will hurt you
so this statement from the report kind
of sounds like 2.2% oxybenzone sunscreen
is fine but if you use 2.3% then you're
going to pee blood or grow a third arm
the worms in your eyelashes are going
to make unsustainable farming choices
but if there's good evidence that terrible
things happen at 2.3% it would be super-villain
level irresponsible to let people use 2.2 percent
what if someone uses a bit more sunscreen
than they should? what if you scrape your
skin and extra sunscreen gets in? what if
some water in that sunscreen evaporates and
that 2.2% gets a bit more concentrated? what
if it turns out that one of the pieces of data
they used for that 2.2% wasn't quite
right? what if a new study comes out?
so there is a big buffer put in
when setting these safe percentages
we can think of it more as a spectrum
there's a region where scientists can
confidently agree that something would not be
harmful based on current info there's also a
region where scientists can confidently agree that
something would be harmful based on current info
but there's also this big gray area in between
because in reality there's always some level
of uncertainty and variation people can use
products differently respond to ingredients
in different ways studies don't always translate
easily to actual human use new data can come out
so "not safe" in the safety assessment
doesn't necessarily mean harmful it means
further into that grey zone than the EU
has decided that they're comfortable with
this is one of those places where that
"opinion" part comes in different regions
have different approaches to
working out their limits but
how far is that current US previous
EU limit of 6.6% along the spectrum?
to find out we can read…
the rest of the sccs report
if you watched my video on clean beauty how safe
or dangerous something is - the risk
- depends on both hazard and exposure
a hazard is something that's potentially
harmful like a lion or even a rabbit you
could trip over it it could convince you to do a
whole bunch of messed up stuff but even
a lion isn't always going to be harmful
if it's very far away in a cage we have
practically no exposure to it so even
though it is hazardous it has that potential
the actual risk of harm to us is very low
if our exposure is high we're
in the cage with the lion then
the risk changes and becomes very
high even though it's the same lion
this concept is sometimes referred
to as the dose makes the poison
so for a safety assessment of a cosmetic
ingredient the sccs will look at both exposure
and hazard to work out the overall
risk they put that lion into context
for exposure the sccs worked
out how much oxybenzone 95% of
consumers would be reasonably exposed
to so they try to capture normal use
if you're eating sunscreen on toast every
morning it's not going to be as relevant for you
for most ingredients in beauty
products the main way that we're
exposed is by absorbing it through skin
sometimes there are other ways that it
gets into your body like breathing
in a spray or eating some lip balm
here are some of the factors that they take
into account most of these are probably
things you expect if you have an ingredient
that absorbs easily through skin you'll have
a high exposure it's also high if it's a
leave-on product if it's used in products
at high percentages if it's in a product that
gets used in large amounts or very frequently
I want to highlight this bit aggregate
exposure this is if the ingredient turns
up in more than one of the products that you use
every time I post about toxicologists doing safety
assessments someone will ask if it's in
more than one product couldn't it add up
yes it could and toxicologists
do take this into account
for the oxybenzone calculation they use 9.9% as
the fraction of the total applied that would be
absorbed into blood they estimated this from a
study using skin samples but they weren't quite
satisfied with the methodology so they took the
average absorption which was 3.1 percent and added
two standard deviations to it to get 9.9 percent
so the number that they're using is more than
three times the actual measured average from the
study most people would probably absorb a lot less
so you can see how they're quite
conservative with their estimates
whenever there's uncertainty they
usually will add extra buffer
to work out how much oxybenzone was put on the
skin in the first place they used the average
sunscreen application amounts from a couple of
studies which was 18 grams of body sunscreen
now some of you are probably
typing in the comments
"I apply much more than 18 grams on
my body that's what the guidelines
say I could be using a dangerous amount
because I'm following the guidelines"
this will make sense in a bit
so from this info they calculate an SED the
systemic exposure dose which means how much
of the ingredient you would be exposed to in a
whole body sense they did this for an average
60 kilo person using these average amounts of a
sunscreen with the maximum six percent oxybenzone
so for example for body sunscreens they
calculated the SED to be 1.8 milligrams
of oxybenzone per kilo body weight per day
so that's exposure the sccs
assessments also look at the hazard
first they go through all of
the relevant data about the
ingredient and how it could potentially be harmful
this includes things like skin irritation
allergies cancer fertility problems
damage to DNA endocrine disruption
they look at tests on cells tissues
animals and information from computer
models they also look at human data for oxybenzone
there are some examples of clinical
studies and volunteers like the FDA
studies from those "sunscreens
absorb into blood" headlines
on top of this they look for examples
of people actually being harmed by that
ingredient and if there's population level
data that's been analyzed to find links
they also look at information on similar
ingredients that could be extrapolated
based on all of this they pick a dose that
they expect to cause little to no harm
for most cosmetic ingredients they use something
called the no observed adverse effect level or the
NOAEL this is the highest amount of the ingredient
that didn't cause a harmful effect in studies
now none of the chemical sunscreens commonly
used in the EU or the US have been recorded to
cause harm in humans outside of things like
allergic reactions and irritation which can
happen with pretty much any skin care ingredient
but that's not what we care about we want to
know about the longer term health effects that
organizations like the ewg keep claiming our
products are causing cancer endocrine disruption
birth defects I'm kind of joking but at the same
time these are the health effects that freak us
all out the most so for chemical sunscreens there
isn't a lot of human data this is a good thing
because it is real world evidence that there's
been no clear serious health effects in all the
millions of people using oxybenzone since it
was launched in the 1970s but at the same time for
the purposes of a safety assessment it's less good
it means you either have to a feed oxybenzone to
people until something bad happens and scientists
aren't allowed to do this anymore except in
movies or B you have to translate information
from less relevant studies mostly animal studies
animals are similar to humans in many ways but
they aren't the same so scientists have to try to
convert what happens in an animal to what happens
in a human and how accurate this translation is
can vary a lot depending on the ingredient and
the animal chocolate and rat poison are both toxic
to dogs but I'm not going to stop eating chocolate
and I'm definitely not going to start eating
rat poison so this approximation adds another
layer of uncertainty and this is is another place
where that scientific opinion comes in there can
be different approaches to interpreting each piece
of data with different pros and cons and a lot of
the time more than one approach is considered
scientifically legitimate so for oxybenzone
the sccs picked 14 endpoints from mouse and rat
studies 14 harmful effects that could be relevant
to humans then out of these they pick the one with
the lowest no Al this was from a study on pregnant
rats being fed oxybenzone in this study when
the rats were fed a lot of oxybenzone they saw a
whole bunch of stuff happen to the rats including
significantly reduced AGG which is the distance
between the Peach Pit and the cherries some
scientists had to use a microscope to measure this
which I think is a pretty good setup for a joke
when rats were fed less but still quite a lot they
only saw one potentially bad effect less sperm
producing cells in male rat fetuses so the sccs
picked one dose lower from the study for the Noel
okay so now that we have these two numbers the
lowest safe exposure level from relevant animal
studies and the actual exposure that consumers
get we're ready to do the margin of safety
calculation basically how much are we getting
with normal sunscreen use compared to their safe
amount the first row of this table shows that the
margin of safety for a body sunscreen is 38 so
in other words if a 60 kilo person applied 18
grams of 6.6 oxybenzone sunscreen to their whole
body and absorb about one tenth of it they would
be expected to get 1 38th of the safe amount but
the sccs wants a margin of safety of 100 to take
into account uncertainty things like converting
between rats and humans if some people react
worse than others incomplete data they want
the average person to only get one percent
of that safe amount so that's why they dropped
the percentage allowed from six percent to 2.2
percent that's how much would give a 60 kilo some
1 100th of that Noel if you wanted to actually
hit that no Al you would have to use a hundred
times the average amount which I don't think
even sunscreen nodes do or the average person
would have to use sunscreen with 220% oxybenzone
now keep in mind that on top of this margin
of safety of 100 there are a
lot of other safety buffers
for example the effect that they care about
is a drop in sperm cells in a male rat fetus
developing fetuses are a lot more sensitive
than children or adults the vast majority of
people using sunscreen aren't pregnant
the amount that actually caused the bad
effect in the study was three times higher
than the safe amount that they use for the
calculation and as I mentioned earlier the
average amount actually absorbed in the skin
absorption study was three times lower
than what they used in the calculation
so if you're wondering how much
you'd need to use to actually
have the smallest harmful effect based
on the same data and assumptions the
sunscreen would have to have about
two thousand percent oxybenzone
and that's for a harmful effect on a male fetus
assuming it's the same for humans and rats
it's also worth mentioning that the
scientists who did the rat study
didn't think that the sperm cell
effect was that important the safe
level that they indicated they would
have picked was about 10 times higher
now I'm not saying that I disagree with
the sccs they're deciding what a good
policy is for a population including people
who are pregnant with a male fetus although
probably not a male rat fetus and if
you're deciding for a population with
millions of people then a tiny decrease
in health risk can make some difference
on top of that there are tons of other sunscreen
ingredients available in the EU most European
sunscreens don't even use oxybenzone anymore
so it isn't like sun safety will be massively
impacted by this change but at the same time
you can see how cautious they're being there's
the massive margin of safety the buffers
that they add whenever there's uncertainty
on top of that the new limit comes from
new data from an animal study there's
no evidence that six percent or six hundred
percent would actually be harmful to humans
so not safe according to an EU safety
assessment really doesn't mean that
you should panic if you've been using
6% oxybenzone sunscreen the whole time
even though the EU is known for being really
conservative when it comes to safety it still
isn't like the EU regulators have gone around
knocking 6% oxybenzone sunscreens out of people's
hands and they haven't made any announcements
telling people to throw out their sunscreens
this report was published in March
2021 the limits came into place July
2022 then companies have another 12
months to stop selling the products
that are over the limit that is two
and a bit years between the finding
of "not safe for the consumer" and no
longer having the products available so
this really highlights that "not safe" and
harmful to your health are very different
so that's the story for body products why
is the limit different for face products?
as you might have guessed from this
whole explanation you apply a lot
less of a face product on a smaller area of skin
the sccs found a margin of safety of 447 for
a face cream with 6% oxybenzone so that was
confirmed to be safe this was for an application
amount of about a quarter teaspoon so you could
apply that four times a day and still stay
under that one percent margin of safety
let's take a quick look at the sccs safety
assessments for the other sunscreen ingredients
octocrylene was confirmed as safe at up
to 10% for humans the exception was with
sprays when used in combination
with other products taking into
account that aggregate exposure then it
would have a margin of safety of 92 so
the limit was lowered to 9 percent to
get it back to a margin of a hundred
homosalate was found to be not safe
at 10 percent the limit was lowered
to 0.5 percent for body products
and 7.34% for face products this
is actually a bit of a problem for body
sunscreens homosalate is good at keeping
other sunscreen ingredients dissolved so
there's going to be a lot of reformulating
for both of these the sccs found that there
wasn't enough evidence to say
they're endocrine disruptors
for 4-mbc the sccs said there was enough evidence
that it "may act as an endocrine disruptor and has
effects on both the thyroid and estrogen systems"
there wasn't enough data to work out what the new
limit should be but they did say it would be
lower than the current limit of four percent
octinoxate and titanium dioxide
will also be reassessed soon
so what should you do? if you're a more cautious
person you might be wondering if you should switch
to sunscreens that follow these new limits or even
avoid these ingredients completely just in case
I can't give you personal advice everyone's
risk calculus is different it's really a
conversation you should be having with
your doctor but generally speaking there
are some useful takeaways from
these safety assessments that
are worth considering when working
out your personal pros and cons
exposure and dose how much sunscreen you use and
how often is important the SCCS assessment got to
their limit based on using 18 grams a day but
you might be applying a lot more or a lot less
for example I only apply full body sunscreen
a few days a year when I go to the beach but
someone who works outdoors might be applying
and reapplying several times a day most days
vulnerability is also important I'm not
talking about sharing your childhood
trauma to do well in a reality TV
show it's whether the risks of a
particular sunscreen ingredient
are especially relevant for you
the most common concern is probably pregnancy
a developing fetus is more strongly affected by
all sorts of things alcohol aspirin camembert
cheese as we saw these safety assessments do
look at what happens to developing fetuses
and a lot of limits are set based on that
but if you're pregnant you would have
more reason to consider temporarily
lowering your exposure to risks
even if just for peace of mind
the other side of the equation is also
important what are the costs of not using
that sunscreen ingredient you might consider
things like a family history of skin cancer
how much UV exposure you get and whether or
not you have access to suitable alternatives
are other sunscreens available where you
are and within your budget? will stretching
your budget make you underapply? is
protective clothing appropriate for
whatever you're doing? I've talked about hats
umbrellas and UV protective clothing before
I think it's also worth noting that
safe limits for cosmetic ingredients
will be constantly changing based
on new data or new regulations or
new procedures for working out safety there
is always going to be some uncertainty and
I know that at a gut level that does
feel uncomfortable we humans haven't
really evolved to be okay with uncertainty
when it comes to potentially harmful things
but it's worth remembering that everything is
potentially harmful we just don't necessarily
think of them that way because we don't see
announcements about new risk assessments
and these adjustments are actually a good
sign that the system is working the way it
should rather than a sign that something
has gone wrong the vast majority of the
time these changes have happened because
of new data from models and experiments
not because people have gotten hurt from
using products with these ingredients
it's a nice reminder that there is research
happening there are experts putting the new
research into context against all of
the other evidence and updating the
guidelines regularly to make the products
that are already pretty darn safe even safer
I hope this video was useful thank you to everyone
who helped me with the script Mo's
Skin Lab is also on YouTube check him
out if you want more from me hit the
subscribe and the nerdification bell
I'm on instagram tiktok and my blog as well
more videos are popping up around me